how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course everything relating to the MCU
today we have some awesome
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 plot
details a lot of this new information
coming from James Gunn the director of
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 2 and the
upcoming 3 himself and another
incredibly reliable source and
unfortunately it sounds like there's
going to be a major death in volume 3
much like there was with Groot in volume
1 and then yondu and volume 2 so for
those who may think that Marvel movies
don't really have that high of stakes
because nobody really dies that often
that is not going to be the case with
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 and
we'll talk about everything we know in
this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe when notifications turned on
to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and tomorrow look
out for the giveaway winner I'll be
announcing the winner in a video
tomorrow night so as I mentioned before
most of this information actually comes
from James Gunn recently on Instagram he
did a live Q&A in which fans asked him
questions and he replied and from his
answers we learned a little bit about
what to expect and one ties back to a
very old leak about guardians of the
galaxy 3 from an account called Roger at
Ward L now many of you know Roger Ward L
if not he is the account that leaked all
of the 100% accurate information for
Avengers endgame months before Avengers
and game came out he leaked things such
as fat Thor Thanos dined by the hands of
Thor in the beginning of the movie
Captain America and his famous hail
hydra line and Avengers any game and
many many more leaks that turned out to
be true well something else that he said
a while ago was about guardians of the
galaxy vol 3
he said Rockets creator is the High
Evolutionary Drax is in for a big
surprise when he discovers his daughter
is alive rocket also gets a love
interest in the form of lilah nebula and
star-lord will grow into closer friends
now again as I mentioned this accounts
track record is 100 percent and as far
as nebula and star-lord growing closer
together that makes complete sense
because they both lost Gamora but the
past Gamora that was brought to the
present is most likely going to be their
target they're most likely going to go
after her together which means they're
probably going to bond but as far as
Rockets love interest Lila and Drax's
daughter being alive in the film
somebody asked James gun during the Q&A
about that they said heard that Lila and
Jax's daughter Kamaria will be in volume
3 is that true and James Gunn replied
guess we'll have to wait and see
now again considering the fact that
Roger Ward else account has a 100% track
record and James Gunn didn't flat-out
deny it like he does most other things
that are not going to be in the film or
are not true we can pretty much expect
to see Lila and Drax's daughter which
means we will also probably see the High
Evolutionary as well but the real kicker
is why we're going to see Lila and why
we're going to see the High Evolutionary
well James Gunn has stated in the past
that guardians of the galaxy volume 3 is
going to be a lot about Rocket Raccoon
and it said that the High Evolutionary
is his creator in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and if we're having a story
about Rocket it would make sense that
his love interest
Lila will be in the film when James Gunn
was talking about the guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 script in the past after he
got fired and then rehired he said I
relate to Rocket and I feel compassion
for Rocket but I also feel like his
story has not been completed he has an
arc that started in the first movie
continued into the second and goes
through infinity war and endgame and
then I was really set to finish that arc
and guardians three that was a big loss
to me not being able to finish that
story though I was comforted by the fact
that they were still planning to use my
script
[Music]
so James Gunn says that he wants to
finish Rockets story and clearly volume
three is going to revolve a lot around
Rocket Raccoon and his arc but that
might not all be a good thing because
when James Gunn was asked if anybody was
going to die in the movie his response
was yes now of course it is possible
that it may not be rocket racoon that he
is referring to however given the fact
that the script is going to be heavily
revolved around rocket rocket is going
to meet his creator and have a love
interest and James Gunn said that he's
going to finish
his story arc it really does seem like
we could see the end of rocket and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so expect
a lot from vol 3 and James Gunn
including the High Evolutionary a big
story for rocket nebula and star-lord
growing closer together in search for
nebula and if everything is still on
track Adam warlock but how would you
feel if rocket racoon died in vol 3 let
me know what you think about that in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe but with
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on all things relating to the MCU
and also for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter as well as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof